احمد ابو زيد طالب مصري حصلت على منحه
دراسه الطب في جامعه افريقيا العالميه
واللي عمري
حزين جدا اللي بيحصل في السودان حاليا
وفرحتي برجوع لمصر ونجاتي انا وزملائي
على استقبالك الطيب
بهذه المناشده يحاول احمد ابو زيد الحصول
على منحه لاستكمال دراسه الطب في مصر
والذي كان يدرسه في احدى الجامعات
السودانيه قبل عودته باعوبه لمدينه كوم
امبو في محافظه اسوان فرارا من القتال
هناك هذا الامر قد يتطلب تحركا اكبر مما
جاء على لسان وزير التعليم العالي في مصر
لتيسير اجراءات التحاق الطلاب المصريين
العائدين بالجامعات الاطار اللي بنشتغل
عليه في الجامعات الخاصه والاهليه بيتم
استيعابهم مباشره من خلال اضافه نسبه 10%
من هذه الجامعات الاستيعاب ولدنا مباشره
معظم الطلبه سواء كانوا من المصريين
العائدين او من السودانيين النازحين
يواجهون مشكله كبرى تتعلق بعدم قدرتهم على
ارفاق طلبات الالتحاق بالجامعات والمدارس
بالوثائق التي تثبت موقفهم التعليمي وذلك
لانهم خرجوا من السودان على عجاله من
امرهم بسبب الظروف الامنيه هناك هذه
المجموعه من السودانيين لديها كثير من
القصص عما يعانونه مع مراحل التعليم
المختلفه منا محسن بدات امتحاناتها في
السودان ونجت بعمرها عندما زادت وتيره
المعارك وانقطعت اسبابه الحياه هنا كنا
شغالين امتحانات فاينل
وقبل ما تنتهي كان لسه ما خلصنا يوم السبت
اللي هو يوم الضرب ذات وكان عندنا امتحان
وما قدرنا نكمل يعني لضرب قام رجعنا من
الدعوه لو قلت اطلع من الجامعه
لانه ما في ما في جامعه فاتحه ما في اي
مصلحه حكوميه فاتحه عشان انا اقدر اسحب
ورقه عشان اقدر او سع ورقه عشان اقدر اقدم
في جامعه تانيه عشان اقدر اطلع اقرا في
حته ثانيه ابراهيم كان يذاكر للثانويه
العامه في مدرسه سودانيه على ارض مصر
والان تتضارب الاقوال بخصوص موعد
الامتحانات التي تقام عاده بالتنسيق مع
السفاره السودانيه ولكن المستقبل التعليمي
اقل من ان يشغل بال هذا الشاب الغيوري على
بلده شهر شهرين ما فرقت معنا لكن في ناس
فقدت بيوتها
في السودان ماساويه يعني الحمد لله على كل
حال ربنا يصلح على البلد ان شاء الله
وحسبنا الله ونعم الوكيل في في في كل من
كان سبب في الكلام الحاصل ده مستقبل
الدارسين في السودان في مراحل التعليم
المختلفه خاصه الثانويه العامه والتعليم
الجامعي مهدد بسبب الحرب الدائره ويحتاج
لتدخلات عاجله من الاطراف الفاعله لتجاوز
هذه الازمه تامر نصرت العربيه القاهره
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات